Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan, wir treffen uns vor dem Salon, beziehungsweise in den Vorbereitungen
für den nächsten Salon, denn wir haben uns diesmal etwas ganz Besonderes ausgesucht.
Es wird ja viel über Demokratie geredet, wir sind ja auch Demokraten,
aber doch sehr pragmatisch.
Wir sagen, es ist vielleicht ganz gut, dass Leute nicht ewig regieren,
sondern abgewählt werden können und dann durch hoffentlich bessere ersetzt werden.
Aber wir sind ja doch sehr allergisch, wenn so in Sonntagsreden groß das Fest
der Demokratie beschworen wird, bei jeder Wahl gesagt wird, dies ist die entscheidende,
richtungsentscheidende große Wahl.
Wenn diese Reden geschwungen werden, bei denen man denkt, ach so erlebe ich
irgendwie Demokratie alltäglich gar nicht, dann sind wir skeptisch und vielleicht
hilft uns da ein Buch weiter.
Ja, wir haben es als Lese, nee, als Hörerempfehlung bekommen zum Lesen.
Ich wäre jedenfalls nicht einfach so drauf gestolpert.
Und der Titel verrät es nicht auf den ersten Blick, denn es ist die Demokratiedämmerung.
Genau.
Aber es geht nicht nur auf die Demokratie ab, sondern eine Reflexionsstufe höher.
Da, wo wir drüber reden können, es ist eine Abhandlung und damit,
zumindest wird der Untertitel, du wirst ihn uns gleich vorlesen,
das Versprechen, dass der ganze universitäre, wir zeigen euch mal,
was Demokratie ist, einmal ausgeräumt wird.
Ja, so ist es zumindest angekündigt in einer Rezension, die wir gelesen haben.
Das Buch heißt Demokratiedämmerung, eine Kritik der Demokratietheorie von dem
Politikwissenschaftler Veit Selck, der in Darmstadt ist.
Und wir sind vor allem darauf aufmerksam gemacht worden, dass Reinhard Mehring,
der Karl-Schmidt-Experte ist, diese große Karl-Schmidt-Biografie geschrieben
hat, auch dieses bei Surkamp erschienene Buch rezensiert hat.
Und wenn man sich allein mal die ersten Zeilen vergegenwärtigt,
die Reinhard Mehring dazu verfasst hat, dann weiß man schon,
aha, da können wir uns auf etwas gefasst machen.
Und zwar heißt es da, es gehört zu den zahlreichen Ironien des vorliegenden
Buches, einer überarbeiteten politikwissenschaftlichen Habilitationsschrift,
dass es bei Surkamp erschien, dementiert es doch mit kaltem Spott den ganzen
linken und linksliberalen Mainstream,
der mit der Surkamp-Theorie-Reihe und Habermas in die alte und mittlere Bundesrepublik
gelangte und zur Standardlektüre aller Intellektuellen wurde.
Also hier haben wir es mit einem Autor zu tun, der sich mit allen anlegt.
Wer jetzt aber glaubt, das sei einfach ein Karl-Schmidt-Buch, nein, keineswegs.
Karl-Schmidt zum Beispiel wird viel weniger zitiert als Niklas Luhmann.
Jetzt sind wir noch nicht, wir haben es ja noch nicht gelesen,
jetzt wissen wir noch nicht, ob zustimmend, ablehnend.
Er arbeitet sich sehr viel an Habermas
ab und arbeitet sich aber dann auch grundsätzlich an der Demokratie ab.
Auf der Klappe steht, es gibt weder Anzeichen für eine Revitalisierung des demokratietheoretischen
Paradigmas innerhalb der wissenschaftlichen Diskussion,
noch Indizien einer Redemokratisierung der politischen Praxis.
Also wir haben da es mit zwei Dämmerungen auf einmal zu tun.
Also ich bin aus zwei Gründen sehr interessiert an diesem Buch.
Zum einen möchte ich wissen, was bleibt eigentlich übrig, wenn man mit scharfem
Blick auf die gegenwärtigen Demokratietheorien schaut.
Wie sie gelehrt und dann eben in Fernsehsendungen auch praktiziert werden, was bleibt übrig?
Und zweitens, wie gegenwärtig kann man eine Demokratiekritik formulieren?
Denn jetzt stürzen sich ja sehr viele auf diese ganz alten platonschen Demokratie.
Wenn alle teilnehmen, ist das sozusagen dem Pöbel hingeworfen und es bleibt nichts übrig.
Und irgendwie finde ich das einen ganz faszinierenden Gedanken,
weil wir das erste Mal in dieser Position sind, in dieser Situation,
in der wirklich alle einfach an Demokratie teilnehmen.
Über TikTok, über was auch immer. Und sei es nur, dass man von,
keine Ahnung, 100 Kurzvideos am Tag, die man sieht, mal zwei mit politischem Ansinnen sieht.
Wenn jetzt alle Parteien glauben, da müssen wir auch hin.
Also statt dass man weiter die alten Publikationsräume schützt und sagt,
wer dabei sein will, wer mitreden möchte,
informiert sich halt hier, wird einfach mittlerweile akzeptiert,
dass jeder sich überall irgendwie informieren kann und eine wertvolle Stimme in der Demokratie ist.
Und das wird jetzt mal überprüft, ob das überhaupt funktioniert.
Und wir sehen ja eigentlich bei allen Autokraten, die es so gibt,
dass sie immer noch Wahlen veranstalten.
Also es ist nicht so, also die meisten, es gibt natürlich auch welche,
wo es gar keine Wahlen gibt, aber so Art Königreiche dann, aber Putin veranstaltet Wahlen.
Nein, wir werden auch ja bei Trump nicht eine Demokratiekritik vorfinden in dem Sinne,
dass er sagt, das System Demokratie funktioniert nicht, sondern er sagt ja,
die Demokratie ist von den Demokraten verraten worden, ich bringe euch die wirkliche Demokratie.
Das heißt also, die Demokratie ist ein dauerhaftes Argument auch für Autokraten
zu regieren, wenngleich sie dann die Demokratie so beschneiden,
dass ihre Regentschaft geradezu ewig wird.
Es heißt dann noch im Klappentext, in der Theorie vielleicht eine gute Idee,
versagt nur leider in der Praxis. Was früher vom Kommunismus gesagt wurde,
gilt heute für die Demokratie.
Sie wirkt zunehmend unglaubwürdig.
Und ich glaube, das ist etwas, was wir auch alle nachvollziehen können.
Und je lauter so die Größe, Stärke und das Wunderschöne der Demokratie beschworen
wird, desto mehr hat man ja insgeheim den Verdacht, oha, also hier hat man große
Angst, dass da etwas verloren geht.
Und deswegen versucht man jetzt in so einer Überaffirmation über das hinweg
zu täuschen, was eigentlich im Argen liegt.
Insofern bin ich sehr gespannt auf diese Lektüre.
Es ist auch nicht ganz so lang, es sind 300 Seiten, natürlich dicht sicherlich
in der theoretischen Auseinandersetzung,
aber glaube ich genau die richtige Grundlage für die Wahlen,
die in diesem Jahr anstehen, nämlich die Europawahl und die Wahlen im Osten
und natürlich auch die US-amerikanische Wahl.
Wir haben ja sowieso dieses super Demokratiewahl, die halbe Welt darf einmal wählen.
Jetzt wo du es nochmal angesprochen hast, es gab ja immer diesen Spruch im Sozialismus,
ich meine jetzt den sehr undemokratischen, den wir hatten, galt, alles ist für alle da.
Und jetzt haben wir eine Demokratie, die auch irgendwie sagt,
sie ist für alle und für alles da.
Und wir können mal gucken, ob sie genauso leistungsfähig ist wie dieser Sozialismus.
Dann heißt es nicht sehr.
Oder ob da noch irgendwo schlummernde Kapazitäten lauern, das alles aufzufedern und abzufangen.
Also ich glaube, das ist genau die Lektüre für den Moment.
Und wir haben eine gute Grundlage für das Buch von Richard David Precht,
das ja dann einen Monat später erscheint und er wird sich ja mit Außenpolitik
beschäftigen und die ist ja sehr stark von diesem Paradigma jetzt geleitet,
Autokratie versus Demokratie, jetzt müssen wir aber erstmal einen kritischen
Blick auf die Demokratie wagen,
bevor wir damit durch die Welt ziehen und glauben damit missionieren zu können
und das ist ja wohl auch was, was Richard David Precht in seinem Buch zumindest
in Zweifel zieht, dass das eine gute Strategie ist.
Also darüber sprechen wir, das geschieht alles im Salon, im letzten Salon ging
es hoch her, da haben wir gesprochen über die Religion, die man nicht mehr braucht,
aber man muss doch wohl an etwas glauben,
man muss zumindest festhalten, es gibt nur dieses eine Leben und wir sind aber
dann irgendwann weggekommen von diesen Religionsdiskussionen und Glaubensdiskussionen
hin zu Marx und ich muss das hier nochmal deutlich erwähnen,
dieses Buch, dieses eine Leben,
mit dem wir auch unsere Probleme hatten, war aber immerhin so gut,
dass es Stefan zum Marxisten gemacht hat.
Also wer das noch hören will, soll das im Salon tun. Nein, du darfst jetzt gar nicht widersprechen.
Sag uns nur noch, wie man in den Salon kommt.
Nein, ich will gar nicht widersprechen, dass Heckel und mich auch zum Marxisten
gemacht haben. Ich will es nur noch mal klarstellen, was für eine Art von Marxismus.
Denn während wir uns ja immer alle fragen, braucht man im Kommunismus noch Geld,
finden wir eine Eine etwas vulgär ausgedrückte Zeit ist Geld zeitmarxistische
Analyse aller Zeiten vor.
Und die ist natürlich, da ich ja immer darauf Wert lege, dass es auch die Zeitdimension
gibt, die Übersehene neben der Sache und den Personen, besonders wertvoll gewesen.
Auch wenn man an dem Buch sehr wie in so einer Mine mit seiner eigenen Spitzhacke
reingehen musste, um das da rauszuholen.
Also in den Salon kommt man auf neue20er.de. Wir sind noch ein Podcast mit eigener Webseite.
Wer irgendwann schon mal Anlaufstelle für seine Lieblingspodcasts gesucht hat,
man hat ja gar keine Webseiten mehr.
Man ist nur noch auf Spotify und iTunes-Katalog-Einträgen. Das finde ich sehr
schade. Also wir haben noch eine eigene Webseite, die heißt neue20er.de.
Und da ist ein goldener Button, da steht Salon drauf. auf und den klickt man
einfach an und ab dann sollte es eigentlich selbsterklärend sein.
Also man macht sich einen Account bei Steady oder wenn man schon einen hat,
nutzt man seinen Patreon-Account oder wenn man es super easy mag und über das
iPhone hört, kann man einfach da im Feed der neuen Zwanziger,
den man also eh schon abonniert hat,
einfach die kostenpflichtigen Dinge auch anklicken und dann hört man den Salon.
Ansonsten bei Steady dort einmal im Monat erscheint der Salon,
in dem wir zehn Texte besprechen.
Ein gemeinsames Buch, zehn weitere Texte wahrscheinlich werde ich auch mal ein
paar mehr Bücher jetzt im April, beziehungsweise dann Mai-Salon dabei haben.
Ich bin gespannt und die Live-Salons sind da auch zu hören und das gesamte Archiv
steht dann allen zur Verfügung.
Das ist die einzige und ich würde auch sagen beste Möglichkeit zugleich,
diesen Podcast zu unterstützen.
Vielen Dank für die, die das schon tun. Wir freuen uns auf weitere und wünschen
einen guten Monat und wir hören uns am Ende des Monats.
Bis dann! Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020.